yeah i'm ready to shoot
uh 20 minutes huh no i'm ready now it's
got to be now
20 minutes [ __ ] hey no hey jack
i'm ready to shoot now my [ __ ] is ready
i want to [ __ ] let's go 20 minutes
i want to [ __ ] who's it going to be what
who do you want to start [ __ ] me or
him
me shut up okay i didn't do anything to
you
what you're not even an actor man you
got no business being here you're not a
[ __ ] actor
yes i am no no no i'm an actor man i'm a
real [ __ ] shut up
what shut up [ __ ] come on
i want you to go in there i want you to
cool off
okay just come on and we'll come back
we'll shoot you soon i said i'm ready to
shoot
not now i'm not gonna tell you again
jack
i'm not gonna shoot you in the state
you're in what do you mean state
state state of california i know where
the [ __ ] i am jesus christ
you've been up for two days no i haven't
been up for two days
nevertheless you look like you haven't
been disliked so i
ain't gonna shoot you this way cause you
don't look good
you know what you don't tell me anything
okay really
you're not
i'm ready to shoot the scene i want to
shoot the scene i'm fine
i want you out of here look it's over
okay
i'm done listen i'm ready shoot it i
want you don't you [ __ ] call me a kid
what the [ __ ] if you want to see me kick
some ass
i don't [ __ ] karate you want to [ __ ]
oh god
come on you are fired you're fired
you're a goddess
you know what i'm the biggest star here
man that's the way it is
i want to [ __ ] it's my big dick so
everybody get ready [ __ ] now
you know what yeah i don't need this
[ __ ] you don't [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] all of you you're not my
boss you're not the king of me
i am the [ __ ] king of dirk you're
nothing without me jack
you're [ __ ] nothing [ __ ] this man i
don't even need her [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i'm so sorry jack i'm so sorry
i'm going to take care of this i'm
straightening out
you